you
all right welcome everybody it is Friday
April 3rd we are over 1 million official
coronavirus cases the real number
probably 5 million 10 million we are
expecting an announcement about masks at
today's press conference which is why
that's in the title on twitch Twitter
Facebook and YouTube we'll see if that
happens if you put a gun to my head is
I'd like to say I'm not a betting man
but if you put a gun to my head and make
me bet I would imagine that they are
going to in order to avoid panicking
people and causing another run on masks
and hoarding they'll say generally
speaking people should wear masks if
they have one especially folks who are
older or immunocompromised that's my so
it'll be sort of like they'll be saying
everybody should be wearing one but
saying it in a way to not make everyone
immediately go out and buy every last
mask that may be available that would be
my prediction for what it is that we are
going to see tonight and or this
afternoon or this evening or whenever it
is that this finally starts starting a
little earlier today because I do have a
hard out at 6:30 p.m. Eastern my mental
health weekend away from this stuff
starts at 6:30 I've got a zoom call with
some friends and then I'm gonna be going
to this great little bistro I love in
Boston and happy
Who am I kidding obviously I'm staying
mahou hell home but I might I might pick
up takeout we're gonna see so anyway
that that's I I want to start earlier to
make sure I get to as many people's
comments and and different things going
on and I do have a lot to talk about
today
let me quickly catch you up on the
latest numbers officially now we are at
just under 1.1 million
official cases we are at fifty eight
thousand five hundred and five deaths
remember there are Trump conspiracy
theorists saying that the death number
is too high the reality is it's too low
there are people who are never getting a
positive test because they there are
there is a shortage or there is not a
post mortem test being done so in
reality this number is low the real
number is probably higher the United
States very very much number
we now have well more than double the
largest number of official cases USA two
hundred and seventy two thousand we are
once again on track for more than a
thousand people dying today
very very sad tragic the official number
of cases here now just what we've been
talking in the last few minutes did go
up to close to two hundred and seventy
three thousand official cases we are
likely to hit seven thousand deaths very
very soon still New York and New Jersey
making up a hundred and thirty two
thousand roughly half of all the cases
but it's going down yesterday it was
like fifty one percent of all the cases
now it's a little bit less so what we
are seeing is other hotspots develop
yesterday we had only Michigan in
California in the five digits now we
have Michigan California Massachusetts
and Louisiana so far Louisiana you will
notice a very similar number of cases as
Massachusetts but double the death rate
almost and a factor there from what let
me be careful I don't I'm not making any
assertions myself because I'm not a
medical expert we should defer to the
medical experts I've read assertions
made that what you are seeing here is
that Louisiana has significantly more
obesity for example than Massachusetts
comorbidities a really big deal when it
comes to this virus and that could
explain why you have roughly double the
death rate in Louisiana importantly
Louisiana is also seems to be behind in
terms of the cases started accumulating
there later so even this death rate
discrepancy may not really represent
what it's ultimately going to be for
example Florida case has started
building later and they still have an
earlier death rate it's believed to be
not because they have healthier or
younger people they don't but because
it's just early a lot of those people as
as tragic and and sort of macabre as it
sounds a lot of the Florida cases are
people who haven't died yet
and Florida has the fifth oldest median
pop age so we're following all of the
numbers updated numbers from the IH
Emmie model this I believe is the best
model right now you can find this
yourself at kovat nineteen
health data org we are now expected to
see the peak on April 16 2020 with two
thousand six hundred and forty four
deaths here in the United States now
importantly this is a range 2644 is the
dotted line here but importantly the the
pink area is anywhere from 1,200 to
4,100 so we don't know exactly every day
we convert another area of dashed line
to solid line because we have real data
and then that fine-tunes these
predictions now this is really really
important the peak is not one day and in
fact it's increasingly looking like what
we would consider a peak could be three
weeks if you look at this we are going
to get over 2,000 deaths per day on
April 8th that's gonna last all the way
until April 27th right that's nineteen
days of peak when you consider that and
you look at the fact that May 1st is
expected to be well worse than today I'm
increasingly of the mindset that there
are gonna be very few restrictions
released on April 30th I at this point
believe we're looking more like May 31st
and in it I get it it sucks it sucks you
don't know how many things I'm
cancelling and everybody's frustrated
we're all kind of in this together but
when you look at the fact that you know
Trump talks about April 30th April 30th
is gonna be a far worse that day than
today every expectation is that we will
be on the downswing from the peak but
today we are expecting what's the
official today we're expecting 1,200
deaths May 1st were still expecting 1600
so I I think we really should be
thinking more of June 1st
rather than May 1st you can also look at
your particular state with this model
this is kovat 19l data org net let's now
look at the total death toll this is
updated every day but importantly you
know when when the doctors talk about
240,000 or whatever that's not for wave
1 they're expecting 3 waves this wave
which will finish up hopefully around
jus
15 July first there's then another wave
expected in the fall with the flu season
which could be up to 90% as bad as this
one and then a third wave in 2021 this
wave the latest projections are 90 3531
deaths the sort of uh range is anywhere
between 39,000 and a hundred and seventy
six thousand but the the sort of precise
number that now is on the model is nine
three five three one so that's where we
are as of right now not great numbers
but those are the numbers that we have
welcomed if you're watching on Twitter
twitch YouTube and Facebook live we are
going to be starting this press
conference presumably at the top the top
of the hour maybe a little bit later we
are expecting some kind of an
announcement about masks today that is
that is my expectation let me say thank
you to Adrienne benningfield who just
sent me a $5 super chat on YouTube so
appreciate the super super chat support
your super chats will show up on the
bottom left of the screen Adrienne says
David when your hair is messed up again
can you yell comic hemay a-- yeah so I
haven't shaved in weeks at this point
and it's been a long time since I got a
haircut so expect it this is going to
last and at some point I may do some
something where I cut my own hair
we'll see but that not today not today
HS DTE says please tell Emily dilly I
love her okay Emily HS DTE loves you
Christian birdie L says Trump said the
US was going to be number one he was not
wrong
we are certainly number one in cases
that's for sure Stephanie Wagoner says
anyway you could set up a national fund
raiser for the Postal Service that would
be difficult for me to do I'll be
perfectly frank I don't know that that's
something I could easily do myself pair
Taryn says is the pink area the
confidence interval or something else
yeah you might have sent that pair
before I mentioned it but the pink area
here is the confidence interval the
dotted line is the most precise specific
estimates so far and waffles pure awful
says are you ready for elements of press
conference all okay so let me let me
deal with that in one second but before
I do that let me say a few thank-yous
Paul Browder
has just signed up on my website join
pakman.com thank you Paul
Carli Marie Rhea's Dimovski has signed
up in his new member number two
Brandon Murphy his new member number
three and Dan Linden balm is new member
number four or Linden balm oh yes so two
days ago when I mentioned that we lost
almost 400 members in March because of
the virus that it would be a great time
for people to sign up my web site
instantly crashed because of the demand
there were like a hundred people trying
to sign up at the exact same time we
doubled the power of our web site and
yesterday we had something like 40
people sign up the web site performed
beautifully so we are again today
monitoring I will remind you we really
appreciate everybody who's signing up at
join pakman.com you are what is sort of
keeping things remotely level through
this belt-tightening
that we're all going through as I've
said before I don't want your last two
bucks but if you're in a financial
position where you're not super
negatively affected by the virus
consider getting a membership at join
pakman.com and the coupon code 2020 now
is a 66% discount don't feel obligated
to take it but feel free and that'll
drop a monthly membership to two bucks a
month a yearly membership to 20 bucks so
I really yesterday the website held up
let's see how it's doing right now right
now the website is performing quite well
I will tell you we are now running at 19
percent CPU usage and 50 percent RAM
usage with a total of seven people
somewhere in the signup process so this
is really important because next
Thursday we're running like a single day
membership drive where I hope the
website is going to be brutalized by
traffic and we want to make sure I just
almost spilled an entire glass of water
which would have shut down everything
but
we're we're stress testing the website
so to speak okay let me tell you about
an element of fun that we are going to
introduce today okay yesterday I asked
for your help coming up with possible
bingo bingo board for these press
conferences these press briefings are
toxic and that they're riddled with lies
and disinformation we are in a tragic
situation but we're gonna add an element
of fun okay this doesn't minimize any of
the tragedy of what's going on I am
going to paste a link momentarily in the
YouTube and twitch chat and you are
going to be able to generate your own
bingo card okay so the way this is going
to work is I'm gonna paste the link you
will be able to go in and generate a
card everybody's card will be you know
slightly different obviously there's all
only so many combinations here and it is
an interactive bingo board which we will
be able to play today during the press
conference okay here are the elements of
the bingo card which you guys all
suggested to me yesterday Trump not
taking responsibility for something when
asked okay Trump using the phrase many
people have said Trump visibly sweating
during the press conference Trump
getting an actual difficult question and
making either Mike Pence or a doctor
answer the question
Trump saying like you've never seen
before or an equivalent phrase
equivalencies are okay Trump referring
to the invisible scourge and actually
pronouncing it in this way rather than
rather than the appropriate way Trump
saying that we have either the most or
the best kovat 19 tests Trump using war
language when referring to the virus
Trump talking about something very
strongly Trump saying industry as
industry which is something he
frequently does Trump doing the Sur
routine so let me explain that one the
sir routine is when Trump recalls a
conversation someone had so he'll say
you know these doctors they came to me
they said sir
this is gonna be a pandemic that's the
sir routine as we have come to know it
Trump mentioning either hydroxy
or a z-pack instead of a free square we
put tremendous in the middle because
Trump just so frequently uses that that
it's almost like a free square so
tremendous is the middle square Trump
looking visibly bored and orange while
someone else is speaking Trump referring
to a nasty question Trump saying
something was either perfect or
beautiful that can refer to a test that
could refer to a phone call
whatever Trump saying that we're looking
at it when he doesn't really have an
answer for a question he'll say that
that's something we're looking at
elements of course is on here elements
has to be here saying that no one who
could have predicted some something
about the coronavirus saying he knows
Blanc better than anyone like when he
said on Sunday I know South Korea better
than anyone and then misstated the
population of Seoul Trump swivelling at
the waist while someone talks very often
when someone else is speaking Trump will
stand there and he will swit his entire
body will swivel at the waist like he
doesn't turn his neck his head at his
neck he swivels at the waist so that is
that's another
sorry that was bad I don't know how long
I was gone that I didn't notice what I
just did okay
Trump mentioning shot China his weird
pronunciation of China Trump mentioning
ratings blaming Obama which also
includes talking about inheriting
something bad from the previous
administration and then lastly when he
says that he either has high marks or
grades himself an A or a 10 out of 10
okay so that's the bingo card
let me now paste the link so you can
generate your own I'm gonna paste it a
few times in YouTube chat moderators
please make note of it so that you can
continue pasting it and then I'm pasting
it in twitch if I also put the bingo
card on Twitter but I don't have a link
there okay so if you're watching live on
Twitter or watching live on Facebook
you're gonna have to come to either
twitch or YouTube where we have pasted
the link you then can generate your own
card and then hit that you understand
we'll all be playing along we'll all be
playing along today and that is that's
where we are for now when it comes to
the bingo card just a little something
that we're doing okay let's see how the
website is holding up the website is
starting to get attacked a little bit
not in any kind of malicious way but CPU
usage has doubled from 15 to 30%
we have 14 people actively in the
membership sign up process but it's
holding steady and it looks like
performance is still okay so that's it
that's a beautiful beautiful thing let
me say thanks to Brandon Parks who is
new member number five today Alex Koepke
is new member number six
Jose Diogo is new member number seven
today rod Beauregard is new member
number eight and Adrian benningfield is
new member number nine today at join
pakman.com beautiful and the website is
holding right up folks now would you
guys be interested to know 70% of the
people on the website right now are on
desktop whereas 27% are on mobile and 4%
are using a tablet can you imagine that
only 4% of the people right now on my
website are using a tablet the
or you know the more you know okay let's
see here
super chats are coming in let's see what
people are saying here um where are we I
don't want to miss anybody here Bryan
Holaday says have you seen governor De
Santis response to Kovac yeah well it's
been terrible and then today he's
starting a stay at home order you know
what can you what can you do
Jamie says what is Joe Rogan like off
camera just like on camera mark McKay
Lee and dodge Essenza
signs up at the SOI boy level dodging
rain says for those that have to go out
before you enter the house make sure to
change your clothes please be safe
everyone you have to go out before you
enter the house bulky a writer says
thoughts on China challenging American
dominance I have a story on my youtube
channel which is titled is the u.s.
losing superpower status I addressed
that issue there let me say thank you to
Sparky Rathman who has subscribed with
twitch prime and lucid 772 who has
subscribed with prime we are only 5
twitch subscribers away from hitting a
thousand which is a beautiful very very
strong number Khaled Hawass Li says
David what would you do in celebration
when the corona thing is over or if
Trump loses the election well if Trump
loses the election I will celebrate I
don't believe there will be a day when
coronavirus is over I think it's going
to diminish and then increase again in
the fall so sadly for people waiting for
you know kind of like a d-day sort of
think or a VE Day better it may be
better said I don't know that we're
actually gonna get it because I think
it's just going to diminish and then
grow again we may someday get that day
when we have a vaccine like in 2021
after wave 3 and I hate to be depressing
let's see here natty K says do a
livestream fundraiser and shave your
head you know that occurred to me
because
I think this is gonna go on for a while
and it occurred to me maybe there is
some situation in which I would just
shave my head fully on stream and my
beard and then not do anything again and
just let it start growing back out and
it's an idea you know but it's like I'm
not really that interested in shaving my
head but conceivably it's something it's
something I would consider doing Austin
Agyeman says I'm 19 and can't receive a
check WTF am I supposed to do lost my
job I'm a student and still have bills
to pay this is sick yeah I addressed
that on the show a few days ago and a
lot of people aged 18 to 24 are in that
situation jae-hwa H says thanks too
strict lockdown measures and high
expensive number of hospital beds in
Austria we still have relatively few
deaths social democracy rules Anthony
for Ruchi
says thank you for everything you do
David what's the likelihood of
nationwide vote-by-mail do you think I
would put it at about 15%
I'm skeptical we're gonna get a vote by
mail in November
thanks to McMorrow for subscribing with
twitch Prime let me also say thanks to
Stephen Munn Lee Stephen his new member
number 10 at joined pakman.com mark
regala is new member number 11 today
it's hog rule cut suck here
tug rule sick here I'm struggling with
that when is number 12 today evan
manning is new member number 13 today at
join pakman.com and i also want to say
thanks to Dean Tackett who is new member
number 14 today at join pakman.com very
much appreciate the support as i
mentioned we did you know early in the
virus we thought we might be fine at the
show but then we had two big advertisers
drop out and then youtube revenues down
35% and then the membership cancellation
started freely flowing 389 membership
cancellations in March which is why we
are
talking about the membership program and
revitalizing it and why I invite you to
grab a membership at join pakman.com at
any price you can use that coupon code
2020 now we have doubled member website
resources so that they can better handle
people all signing up at one time so far
the website is holding nice and steady
so everybody's experiencing this I don't
want your last two dollars but if you
have two discretionary dollars and you
appreciate the daily streams and videos
and everything consider grabbing a
membership at join pakman.com let's go
through a few clips here I have a few
clips Oh first of all I have a poll on
my Twitter account who disturbs you more
by being at the White House press
briefings the my pillow guy or Jared
Kushner most of you 17900 people voted
and you can vote as well at twitter.com
slash D Pakman I agree that it's kushnir
you know the my pillow guy is a
disturbing religious nut and Trump
sycophant but at least like he's just
making masks and he's trying to help
Kushner is downright sinister okay here
is video of oh sorry this isn't it here
is video of Jared Kushner wait no this
isn't the one here is listen to Jared
Kushner and making a note and about the
stockpile okay listen to what he said
yesterday if in instances where in
cities they're running out but the state
still has a stockpile and the notion of
the federal stockpile was it supposed to
be our stockpile it's not supposed to be
state stockpiles that they then use so
we're encouraging the states to make
sure that they're assessing the needs
they're getting the data from their
local understand we said the federal
stockpile is supposed to be our
stockpile not the state stockpile
doesn't everybody live in a state or
Washington DC like so who are there any
federal residents who aren't also state
residents like everybody lives in a
state they always talk about how this
process is what's that phrase pence uses
locally managed Lois Lee is like locally
managed state-run and federally
supported the states are running the
hospitals the states are running what
does that mean the stockpile is for the
FET for us who is us everybody lives in
a state or Washington DC and you know
this gerbil sounding lunatic showing up
as if he now is an expert in this entire
thing was extremely sinister now there's
one other thing here is as Aaron rooper
says here is Jared Kushner going for the
world record of meaningless corporate
buzzwords in one minute take a listen to
this insanity president asked is that
all of the recommendations that we made
be based on data he wanted us to be very
rigorous to make sure that we were
studying the data collecting data a lot
of things in this country were happening
very quickly and we want to make sure
that we were trying to keep updating our
models and making sure that we were
making informed decisions and informed
recommendations to him based on
meaningless I mean he's he's saying
nothing he's better than Penn State
saying nothing data that we were able to
collect and put together the president
wants to make sure that we had the best
people doing the best jobs and making
sure that we had the right people
focused on all the things that needed to
happen to make sure that we can deliver
in these unusual times for the American
people so it's been 35 seconds he has
said like if you what would be your
takeaway how would you sum up he didn't
say anything he did what what are you
doing Jared what did what is it exactly
you're talking about the president also
instructed me to make sure that I break
down every barrier needed to make sure
that the teams can succeed this is us
can succeed which teams succeed at what
Jared an effort where the government is
doing things that the government doesn't
normally do where we're stretching we're
acting for the government is stretching
and doing things we and the president
wants to make sure that the White House
is fully behind the different people
running the different lines of effort
the way he's behind people making
efforts it's been 55 so okay just three
more seconds that we get everything done
in a speed that the president demands we
get everything done so what what Jared's
saying is we've used data to look at
models because the president wants teams
working effectively supporting others
getting things done that have to be done
at the speed at which the president
wants tell me one thing that you did
Jared give me just one thing oh and
they're full I forgot fully behind yeah
Oh what is this this is weird okay I
didn't know that I guess there's some my
neighbor's texting me that there's an
applause thing going on hold on what's
going on in case you hadn't seen this we
have our alarms set and we'll be on the
porch with bells on when is this
happening 7:00 p.m. tonight maybe okay
anyways the people are doing a thing
here in Boston very very cool
okay so anyway it's completely toxic
presence and so the issue is please come
to my Twitter page twitter.com slash Dee
Pakman I posted this yesterday tell me
who disturbs you more by being at the
White House press briefings the my
pillow guy or Jared Kushner and clearly
it's Kushner based on almost 18,000 of
you who have who have voted so far all
right we're waiting for the press
briefing if you're just joining us we
are expecting an announcement about
masks today clearly there are going more
and more in the direction of saying
really everybody should wear a mask
outdoors but I'm guessing they don't
want to cause a run on masks so they'll
probably say something like if you have
a mask wear it if you have a scarf wear
it etc okay that that's my expectation
for those just joining us we are going
to be playing trump briefing bingo okay
I'm going to paste the link again in
twitch and YouTube chat so you can play
along this will randomly organize the
elements of this bingo card to give
everybody you know within reason
obviously there's only a certain number
of combinations it'll give you your own
card and then as Trump says stuff today
you can check it off and then you can
call out bingo in the chat if you're
watching on Twitter or Facebook I'm
sorry I have no easy way of pasting that
link there but come to twitch.tv slash
David Pakman or youtube.com slash the
David Pakman show
now this might look like a transcript
from a trump press conference to many of
you but we'll see I explained what each
one of these means earlier and I'll be
playing along so don't worry but that's
just a little something that we're going
to be doing let me say
thank you to Lyon doggery for
subscribing with twitch Prime and
valiant hexer who has also subscribed
with prime super chats continue to come
in
Jamal Swift thank says thanks homie
great to see you back Jamal J Johson
says thanks for all you do David thank
you
Vitus arey Eddins has subscribed on
YouTube
BR says love the creativity david koepp
this these streams up thank you
whoops where'd that one go JH WH says
love your hair thanks for the David
Pakman show thank you
actors ER says good luck America from
Norway yeah we're going to need it your
Lord says David is the Sam cedar of
David Pakman Donna Williams says I
remembered to like the stream without
being reminded today thank you for all
you do yep if you're joining on YouTube
and this is a serious request please
like and subscribe like the stream and
hit subscribe my youtube rep has told me
when you get a stream going and people
right away like it and subscribe
YouTube's algorithm believes rightly or
wrongly it could be wrong but YouTube's
algorithm believes that this is a good
stream to recommend to people that's why
I say please lead a professional website
looks like we're starting please
remember to like the stream and hit that
subscribe button and we will be looks
like things are oh here's Jim Acosta
nasty nasty fake news reporter Jim
Acosta looks like we're probably five
ten minutes away let me say thanks to a
few other folks who have grabbed
memberships on my web site
let me say thanks to Timothy Smith whose
new member number fifteen today at join
pakman.com christian serin is new member
number sixteen today let me say thank
you to Travis Newton who's new member
number seventeen today Sean wise is new
member number eighteen today Elzbieta
Marciniak great to have you back to
membership Elzbieta number 19 daniel
Lindroth is new
member number 20 today and Gary Cavin is
new member number 21 also want to say
thank you to John Bolton John Bolton
Thank You Trump's former national
security adviser John Bolton a new
member
listen if John Bolton is a member you
can also be a member at at join
pakman.com let's see how the websites
doing two days ago our website crashed
because of people trying to sign up we
doubled website resources Wow only 25%
CPU usage right now and we've got 20
people right now on the membership in
the membership sign-up process so that's
great that's very good okay Vicky Howell
and Alison Crocker have grabbed YouTube
memberships Christian Birdie else as
governor Rhonda Santa's from Florida is
Ted Cruz part two well said very very
well said unknown prodigy says you
better check the head shaving with the S
oh yeah I mean I listen my girlfriend
would obviously say don't shave your
head but it's if it's if it's a you know
part of some kind of stunt for the show
I'm gonna have to overrule her Jennifer
Senath says one hour to Georgia
shelter-in-place and people are out in
full force
yeah well that's listen that's what's
going to extend and worsen these numbers
right now we're expecting the peak of
deaths on April 16th at 2644 if people
are just out having a party this number
is going to go up this number the total
deaths projected is going to go up and
it's going to get very very ugly that
would be our expectation we'll c-137
says thanks for your ase analysis the
other day appreciate the pragmatism a
lot of people unsubscribed for my
channel because of it but i'm glad that
you appreciated it John Howell says
bingo plus Smok equals sanity in the
moment not sure I understand that one
bulkier writer says geopolitical impact
on China from coronavirus too early to
know and we still don't know the truth
of
even going on there so it would be
premature premature maybe better said
dr. Zack has grabbed a youtube
membership max wall Smart has sent a
super chat John Ettinger and lion dog re
as well as Kaylee Bella mer have grabbed
YouTube memberships Lika
says David you're approaching Sam cedar
scruffiness yeah I mean I why even
bother shaving at this point
Brian Somerville has upgraded his
membership to beta a retro path acts as
this is havehd speak ok lion dog re says
David do not shave your head thank you
for doing what you do you and John
iadarola are the most handsome Wow
excuse me Jill J says thanks for being
you
thanks Jill uh infer inferno it says hey
David I love your show I want to let you
know that you and Kyle kolinsky oh hold
on a second where'd that go you and Kyle
kolinsky both influenced my conversion
from conservative to progressive glad to
have converted you or I like to say
deprogrammed something about
deprogrammed feels more powerful in some
way I don't know let me say thank you to
Erica
Eldred whose new member number 23 today
at join pakman.com slash a blonde
Bergson is new member number 24
Griffin Martin is new member number 25
ladies and gentlemen let's go for 50
let's see if we can do it Hendrick
wonder gem is new member number 26 thank
you so much Hendrick very much
appreciate that
join pakman.com is the place for
memberships as I like to say
whoa 700 new people just arrived on the
YouTube stream that was quick I don't
know what just happened
let's see here Olly P says it looks like
the federal stockpile is non-existent
well I mean listen we don't they claim
it exists I don't know what else to say
Chad Williams says what does Jared's
actual
role in trumps cabinet we don't know
he's I guess kind of like an errand boy
for Mike Pence on the virus that's what
he claims let me say thank you to ginger
bloke for subscribing with twitch Prime
and Kiro kid 1971 Cairo kid you are
subscriber number 1000 on twitch I
appreciate that
Wolfpack says get a haircut you hippie
yeah I'm a actually so there's a couple
different ideas one idea would be I just
shave it at some point in like
completely like actually bigoted on the
basis of some kind of some kind of
element of charity I guess we would call
it the other idea is I try to give
myself a proper haircut with some
clippers or something like that and I
stream it live or maybe I'd film it and
then upload it in case something goes
really really wrong when I was 14 I got
myself a set of clippers and I would cut
my own hair and usually I would use like
a four on top and then I think like a 1
on the sides or something and once just
as a mistake I had the one on and I went
like that and this patch right here was
gone and it was a number 1 and I was
hoping for a number 4 and I think what I
ended up doing was just putting a number
2 on and doing everything a number 2 and
after like a few days this weird golf
ball-sized patch wasn't super noticeable
but you know that's story time I guess I
don't know what else to call it
ok bulky or writer says it feels like
Trump doesn't really care about his
position as a leader or respects the
office of the presidency and it makes me
sick it also feels like Donald Trump
doesn't really care about people and
that's a bigger concern to me Nicholas
says Jared seems to be asking governor's
what their ventilators stock is and
rejecting if they aren't out of
ventilators it's nonsense because
they're preparing for future vent use as
the models predict yeah you know I mean
unfortunately we love to think here in
the United States many of us do that
we're just not going to experience what
Italy and Spain and so many other places
are experiencing
very quickly I mean I was just reading a
very interesting piece of to emergency
room doctors in in New York City
blogging about the last few days they
blogged about like March 26 27 28 29
something like that
they said it's it goes from a few cases
to patients are shoulder to shoulder
everybody even if you're in there for
something other than Co vid you're
probably getting Co vyd they don't have
ventilators and it gets completely
insane so it's gonna happen very quickly
we are going to have to start doctors
are expecting they will have to start
making those rationing type decisions
every indication of that particularly in
New York City and some of the places
that are suffering the most it's gonna
get very very ugly Laurent we Dale says
unemployed supply chain consultant here
potential employer suggestions to help
with efforts Army Corps of engineer
Public Health private wh SC task force
yeah I don't know if you're asking me or
offering suggestions but that reminds me
yesterday Steven minuchin said that by
today people would be able to start
getting low applying for loans at banks
under the Paycheck protection plan I
spoke to my banker today and another
banker at another Bank everybody so far
has said they've got no guidance yet
from minuchin or anybody else that
they're certainly not taking
applications today yet another one of
these things that has come and gone they
didn't do it
when is the money gonna be available one
of the applications gonna be available
the banks have no clue people are
calling banks by the tens of thousands
and the banks are saying we don't know
we just we haven't heard anything yet we
don't know here's the bloomberg reporter
showing up Trump loves referring to him
being from Bloomberg that's another I
should have included in our bingo board
Trump asks Bloomberg reporter about how
Michael Bloomberg is doing we will be
playing bingo today let me paste the
link again for you I'm pasting this in
the YouTube and twitch chats you can
generate your own Trump bingo card and
play along today
and it's something it you know it's
something to add a little bit of levity
to what is a horrible horrible
multi-month nightmare that we are
currently dealing with I invite you to
do it remember if you're just joining us
on YouTube please do press subscribe and
please hit like both of these things
really help our streams and we depend on
people just coming in and saying hey I
like this that tells YouTube suggest
this stream to somebody else who might
be searching around for the press
conference so like and subscribe is very
very important and exciting torille
Backlund has grabbed a youtube
subscription John Ettinger says I just
joined on YouTube I paid for a 20/20
membership back on the first of the year
thank you very much appreciate that
dried mango says police say hi to Jo Jo
my lovely wife we love your show
hi Jo Jo appreciate both of you watching
the streams Polsky says why didn't the
everyone says it make it to bingo
I had a limited number of things so I
couldn't I couldn't include everything
Junie McGraw says do you think Trump
would use this pandemic as an excuse to
postpone the election it's difficult to
do I've got a clip out about that and
because people keep asking I'm not gonna
answer it any time I say that with peace
and love Junie but check out my YouTube
clip on it because I do go into that
insignificant detail okay let me say a
few other thank-yous here who do we got
who do we got
Derrick father be is new member number
27 today at join pakman.com theresa
Crossman is new member number 28 Tony
rice is new member number 29 William
phenergan energon I hope that's the
right pronunciation is new member number
30
Tim Herod is new member number 31
William Frank is new member number 32
Michelle Jankowski is new member number
33 Pedro me Ramon is new member number
34
filip angst a lot of people feeling
angsty that's for sure
Philip is new member number 35 Erin
Cowan has upgraded his subscription
we're gonna count it as new membership
number 36 today and Lewis veering is new
member number 37 today beautiful we've
not gotten to 50 during one of these
streams lately and that is the goal that
is the immediate goal welcome if you're
just joining us we are now 21 minutes
late to this briefing will mean listen
we aren't late we're here Trump's late
we are expecting an announcement about
masks today and we will be playing trump
briefing bingo during the stream I've
put the link in YouTube and twitch our
moderators every once in a while maybe
we'll also paste that link a few times
to start pasting it in and you can play
along and we've got a great bingo setup
where like you know if Trump says
something's tremendous boom I've marked
it off if Trump says China I've marked
it off and then if you get bingo we are
counting diagonals I know we looked very
strongly at diagonals and I am allowing
diagonal bingo wins so though I've
pasted the link a few times and I think
our moderators yes our moderators
Bridget over on YouTube and other people
and sage over on on twitch everybody's
pasting that in so you can participate
with us okay sloths Barham says neighbor
across the street believes this is a
test to see how far the government can
push us he is a lung cancer survivor
yeah I've talked about some of the kovat
conspiracies I've got a clip about that
which you can check out let me say thank
you to Midnight Club for subscribing
with twitch Prime sweet Lou Diamond has
also subscribed with twitch Prime very
very much appreciate that Garrick
Vandervoort says as a fellow J mu Duke I
always hate seeing trumpets attack him
such a good guy and from what I've heard
as a fellow J M
you Duke I'm not I'm just I don't know
who went to James Madison is it pouchy
go there or I mean I guess that's
probably what you're referring to him
fast food films is a new YouTube member
David wrote says missed your comment
yesterday as I left still a member and
still loved the show just not sure
listening to garbage from Trump is in
any way helpful
Tamara darrid has signed up on YouTube
your Lord says the world will not be the
same his true truth Amin al rifai has
subscribed on YouTube Ben Taylor says
have you watched wild wild west on
Netflix I have not
I just watched Tiger King I'm watching
Ozark season 3 I'm watching better call
Saul but no I have not seen wild wild
west
Steve G says have have you seen the clip
of that person in India that thinks
Trump is a god built an idol and
everything I don't understand the
cultist mentality I have not seen that
we've got dr. Burks Jerome Adams I think
that this guy is dr. Redfield I'm not
sure who does anybody know who this guy
is I'm not sure who that is
looks like we're gonna be starting soon
that is one big scarf for sure let me
say thank you to Wilfredo Ramirez whose
new member number 38 at join pakman.com
Christopher build is new member number
39
deborah corbin houston is new member
number 40 today at join pakman.com also
want to say thank you to John Neary who
is new member number 41 today very much
appreciate that and I am pleased to
report to you the website is holding
steady
we have 19 people right now working on
those signups as we speak the website is
holding up beautifully looks like we're
at 29% CPU usage I love it I love it
much more power
powerful website today than we had two
days ago Gibran Rojas has signed up on
YouTube Anthony foutch II says David
please debunk this right-wing argument
leftist say the government is corporate
and bad but you want more of it leftist
must be hypocrites yeah we I will deal
with that next week that's it's a good a
time as any to deal with that
here is Donald Trump get your bingo
cards you can use the links in the chat
in YouTube and twitch we will be playing
bingo during this I just had a meeting
with Kevin McCarthy future Speaker of
the House I hope and he's done a
fantastic job for the people of
California and also the people of
California have done a fantastic let me
maybe try to find a louder stream I jala
everybody out there but I thought I'd
have Kevin say a few words so Kevin
please well thank you mr. president and
I would like to thank you I'm based of
California governor Newsom says the work
that you're doing together as been
working very closely has been effective
in California as well vice president the
president you know today mr. president I
want to thank you especially for the
work this Secretary minuchin has done
especially for small businesses just
today alone
I saw Bank of America had more than
10,000 loans in two hours and for
anybody who's in small business I'm
first football business when I was 20
years old you don't have income coming
in right now you get a loan but for your
rent paying your employees and paying
your utilities is a grant that's part of
the cares Act and I think you're gonna
find that a lot of small business is
gonna hire people back keep them afloat
through the next two months and get this
economy moving again as we get through
this virus hope you're playing along
okay thank you very much everybody and I
want to start by saying that our hearts
go out to the people of New York as they
bear the brunt of the corona virus
pandemic in America that seems to be the
hot spot right now but you have some
others as you know that a very very bad
Louisiana's getting hit very hard parts
of Michigan and getting hit very very
hard
New Jersey is is surprisingly it's much
greater than anybody would have thought
they're doing a really good job
governor's doing a really good I think
we have that hold on New York's first
responders EMTs don't no one could have
seen example courage under pressure
they're the best in the world we will
take every action and we'll spare no
resource financial medical scientific we
will not spare anything we'll get it
back into shape the Empire State
the governor's doing an excellent job
they're all working very hard together
at the request of the governor as you
know the Javits Center we have 2,500
beds and we're going to allow that to be
a system where this horrible disease can
be looked after the patients can be
looked after that was going to be for
regular medical problems such as
accidents and you know it's very
interesting governor's tell me we don't
have too many accidents and a few people
driving so we're going to put that
facility into play which is a big
facility the ship will be staying the
way it is but we're putting that
facility into play to help them and
today also the CDC is announcing
additional steps Americans can take to
defend against the transmission of the
virus I don't think he said invisible
scourge on these we know that the
transmission from individuals without
symptoms is playing a more significant
role in the spread of the virus than
previously understood so you don't seem
to have symptoms and it still gets
transferred in light of these studies
the CD
is advising the use of non-medical cloth
face covering their deaths as an
additional voluntary public health
specialist so it's volunteer you'd have
to do it they suggested for a period of
time but this is voluntary I don't think
I'm gonna be doing it but we know you
have a lot of ways you can look at it as
follows the CDC is recommending that
Americans were a basic cloth or fabric
mask they can be either purchased online
or simply made at home probably material
that you'd have at home these face
coverings can be easily washed or reuse
I want to emphasize that the CDC is not
recommending the use of medical grade or
surgical grade masks and we want that to
be used for our great medical people
that are working so hard and doing some
job medical protective gear must be
reserved for the frontline healthcare
workers who are performing those vital
services the new mask guidelines also do
not replace CDC's guidance on a social
distancing including staying in your
home when possible standing at least 6
feet apart for a period of time again
we're going to all come back together
here we're going to all come back
together and practicing hand hygiene
which we should do anyway a lot of
things I think are going to spill over
shaking hands maybe we'll stay with our
country for a long time beyond this one
of the one of our great doctors was
telling me that as you know we have flus
every year and the number of people
killed by the flu is very substantial it
said that if they didn't shake hands
that number would be substantially lower
so maybe it'll stay maybe some of these
things long-term will be good but those
guidelines are still the best and the
safest way to avoid the infection so
with the masks it's going to be really a
voluntary thing you can do it you don't
have to do it I'm choosing not to do it
but some people and they want to
that's okay it may be good probably will
they're making a recommendation it's
only a recommendations voluntary we also
taking action to ensure the cost of he's
almost saying it like he has to but he's
kind of thing don't really do it resting
or treatment of the coronavirus the
largest insurer nationwide the Blue
Cross Blue Shield system has now
announced that it will not require any
co-pays which is really something that's
a tremendous statement from patients of
the virus treatment there it is the next
60 day similar to the commitments of
Cigna you manna Anthem those are great
companies and they're all doing the same
thing so co-pays for them to do that is
speak statement we appreciate it today I
can so proudly announce that hospitals
and health care providers treating
uninsured corona virus patients will be
reimbursed by the federal government
using funds from the economic relief
package Congress passed last month that
was as per the question yesterday and
actually the day before yesterday this
should alleviate any concern uninsured
Americans may have about seeking the
coronavirus treatment so that's I think
answers the question pretty well and
very much in the favor of our great
people
I'm also signing a directive invoking
the defense production Act to prohibit
export of scarce health and medical
supplies by unscrupulous actors and
profit ears these security and secretary
the Secretary of Homeland Security will
work with FEMA to prevent the export 195
respirator surgical mask gloves and
other personal protective equipment we
need these items immediately for
domestic use we have to have them but
we've done really well with the purchase
of items and you'll be hearing about
that shortly
we've already leveraged the DPA to stop
the hoarding and price gouging of
crucial supplies under that authority
this week the Department of Health and
Human Services working with the depart
of Justice took custody of nearly
200,000 n95 respirators 130,000 surgical
masks 600,000 gloves as well as bottles
many many many bottles and disinfectant
sprays that were being courted all of
this material is now being given to
healthcare workers most of us thought
had been given out and we've given a lot
to New York a lot to New Jersey a lot to
other places in addition to ensure that
healthcare workers in New York have the
protective equipment they need the
federal government in the name of the
Department of Defense is providing about
8.1 million n95 respirators Department
of Defense and we've already given
200,000 of them to New York City mayor
de Blasio needed them very badly so we
got him to marry de Blasio in New York
City you guys believe that very grateful
8.1 million and we're going to be
increasing that number from 8.1 million
to more that's a lot of n95 respirators
today my team spoke with the CEO of our
senior health and the CEO of LCM say the
two largest health systems in New
Orleans they said they feel that they
currently have enough ventilators I
think a lot of people are going to have
enough ventilators and masks and
appreciate what we did and all of the
things we've been doing with them
working with them the CEO of Aashna
Warner Thomas who's really been
fantastic I have to say indicated a need
for 230,000 surgical gowns and I
instructed FEMA to deliver them tomorrow
so they have the 230,000 that's
Louisiana New Orleans 230,000 surgical
gown
them by tomorrow we're expanding the
role of the armed forces in our response
effort because no one is better prepared
to win a war than the United States
military and we are in a war the
invisible enemy remember over 9,000
retired army medical personnel have
answered their nation's call and are now
supporting field hospitals and medical
facilities use this war language by
Arthur we like what I just told you that
Governor Cuomo requested we do something
and Javits where we take it over and
we're gonna have that manned by the
military because it's very tough I heard
invisible enemy not scorched more people
in the New York area so we're gonna have
it manned by the military Javits Center
National Guard members have been
activated to help States build new
treatment centers and assist in the
seamless distribution of medical
supplies that includes National Guard
the National Guard is especially
strongly because the states were in many
cases unable to have the delivery
capability from warehouses and other
places that we put the supplies so I've
given approval to use the National
Guard's of various National Guard's in
the different states and they're doing a
fantastic job of not only protecting
people but delivering material the Army
Corps of Engineers is assessed more than
100 facilities in all 50 states and is
rapidly building temporary hospitals and
alternative care sites in many states in
New York New Jersey Michigan
Pennsylvania Arizona California Colorado
Florida Illinois New Mexico Oregon
Washington Wisconsin Ohio they're doing
a lot of work in just those states plus
additionals that are being will be
announced probably tomorrow but they're
doing some job the Army Corps of
Engineers what a job they're doing and
FEMA what a job they're doing as we
deploy the power of our military we're
also deploying the skill of our doctors
scientists and medical researchers we
continue to study
effectiveness of hydroxy chloroquine and
other therapies and the treatment of
prevention there is and we will keep the
American people fully informed in our
findings hydroxychloroquine I don't know
it's looking like it's having some good
results I hope that that would be a
phenomenal thing but we have it right
now
in approximately now it's increased to
1500 people I spoke with dr. Zucker in
New York
terrific guy by the ways we're doing a
good job and I spoke to Governor Cuomo
last evening and this morning about it
so it's been there for about three and a
half days but I think and what many
other places it's being tested too and
we have a tremendous supply of it we've
ordered it in the case that it works and
it's could have some pretty big impact
so we'll see what happens my
administration is also working to get
relief to American workers and
businesses and day one of the Paycheck
protection program as Kevin said more
than 3.5 billion dollars in guaranteed
loans have been processed to help small
businesses keep their workers employed
during the unprecedented time this
unprecedented time so McCarthy said that
they took applications Trump's acting
like the loans being processed implies
something else or done a great job and
then you have the community banks your
smaller banks and we're already at 3.5
billion dollars going out to incredible
people but that's way ahead of schedule
the SBA and the Treasury are working
around the clock and our banking
partners are really incredible and
they're ensuring that the money gets to
small businesses as quickly as possible
and then the small business in turn take
care of employees that they would have
had to let go and now they'll keep them
and that's good and then they can open
for business and they're gonna have
their employees and we'll try and get
back to where we were eventually we're
going to supersede where we were the
energy industry has been especially hard
hit a nerve Isis this afternoon
met with Greg garland investor 66 so
Dave Hager of Devon Energy Harold Hamm
of Continental Resources Jeff Hildebrand
of he'll be hauling of Occidental
Petroleum Mike summers of the American
Petroleum Institute
Kelsey Warren of energy transfer
partners
Mike worth of Chevron and Darin Woods of
ExxonMobil I informed them that we will
be making space available in the
Strategic Petroleum Reserve to let
American produce a store surplus oil
that can be sold at a later time there's
a tremendous abundance of oil primarily
because of the virus the viruses just
stopped demand of everything including
oil so we're working with our great
energy companies these are great
companies they employ tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of people and
they've kept America really going for a
long time and no big price hikes no big
anything I mean they've just kept it
going and now they got hit but with all
the jobs and all of the good that they
do we're gonna make sure that they stay
in good shape
America is engaged in a historic battle
to safeguard the lives of our citizens
our future society our greatest weapon
is the discipline and determination of
every citizen to stay at home and stay
healthy for a long time articulate
reiden to stay healthy for a long time
so stay at home just as ending this will
end you'll see some bad things and then
you're going to see some really good
things and it's not gonna be too long we
will heal our citizens and we will care
for our neighbors and we will unleash
the full might of the United States of
America to vanquish the virus and with
that I'd like to ask Mike Pence to come
up vice president's say a few words and
we'll have a couple of other quick talks
on a couple of subjects and we'll take
questions
and it's a beautiful Friday in
Washington DC and our country is a great
place and we're getting better we're
getting better very quickly this was
artificially induced so in place said
they said close it down and you have to
close it down we closed it down and
we're healing and we're gonna get it
better fast so Mike if you could come up
say a few words Thank You mr. president
president just outlined a number of the
decision that he made today on the
unanimous recommendation of the White
House coronavirus a task force in
addition some good news dr. deborah birx
will reflect on a moment some of the
areas across America where we see
evidence that the mitigation efforts the
American people putting into practice
the president's coronavirus guidelines
are having a positive effect guys I'm
gonna check off that Trump is looking
bored and Orange he's already doing it I
think I'm gonna take it on my board
merged in our country remain the cases
remain at a steady but low rate and we
know as governor Newsom said yesterday
that they're not out of the woods yet
and continue to flow resources but we
want to commend people in those states
and all across the country we're putting
into practice the social distancing and
all the measures that state and local
leaders are advising and that and that
the president has been advising in the
coronavirus guidelines for America we're
also continuing to track significant
outbreaks in New York they beautify
bright Chicago and Boston and as the
president indicated we're prioritizing
resources to support health care workers
and to support those that are dealing
with the coronavirus in those
communities on the subject of testing
now more than 1.4 million tests have
been performed across the country and as
you all are aware some 266 thousand
Americans have tested positive for the
corona virus Abbot instruments which now
can perform a 15 minute test across the
country
have literally 18,000 of their machines
across the nation today but at the
president's direction FEMA is acquiring
over 1,200 more machines to distribute
to every state public health lab in
America and also to our indian health
care service and the big news of course
over the last few days was at the fda
once again in near record time has
approved an antibody a test developed by
SELEX and we're continuing on the White
House coronavirus task force to examine
ways that we can scale up these rapid
tests and these innovative new tests not
just to meet this moment but to lay a
foundation for testing across the nation
in the months ahead as the president
mentioned he met with energy executives
today and continues to engage with
leaders of businesses all across the
nation we also held two held a
teleconference today with commercial
retailers on the president's behalf we
thanked them for the way that people
that operate malls and shopping centers
around the country have have have have
embraced and enacted the coronavirus
guidelines for America it's had an
enormous impact on their businesses and
their industries but I heard I heard
from them their their patriotic
commitment to put the health of their
associates and their customers first and
it was deeply inspiring on the subject
of supplies the president detailed our
work in that space it continues to this
day
part of our air bridge we had a flight
arrived from China today to Columbus
Ohio we continue to work each and every
day watching the data about cases to
ensure that in particular not just the
personal protective equipment is
available for the health care workers
that are on the front lines but also
that ventilators are available as the as
this epidemic makes its way through
through regions and communities we are
literally working on notice there
increasingly adopting the language that
like this is mostly over but we still
are waiting on 95 percent of the deaths
according to most models
as the president mentioned we've we've
seen over a billion and a half dollars
and loans go out through the Paycheck
protection program today we have
available for questions the head of the
CDC today to speak about the new
guidance sorry I have to interrupt
notice how they just lie so McCarthy at
the beginning said they took 10,000
applications Trump said 3.5 billion in
loans is in process and Penn said that
3.5 billion went out already it none of
that's true only what McCarthy said is
true I'm pleased to report at the
president's direction Medicaid and
Medicare already expanded to coronavirus
treatment and testing early on and of
course the president just indicated how
major insurance companies across the
country are not just waiving co-pays on
testing but they're now waiving co-pays
for at least 60 days on any any
coronavirus treatment but now as
secretary Hayes our will enumerate and
now we'll make sure that any American
even those that have no insurance will
be able to receive treatment in a
hospital and never have to worry about
the bill I just give a gentle reminder
to every American if there is evidence
across the country that you're putting
into practice the coronavirus guidelines
for America every American has a role to
play and I want to thank you on behalf
of the President and and and all of the
American people for the way that you're
stepping forward you're engaging in the
social distancing and doing the things
that will slow the spread we encourage
you to keep on keeping on we will get
through this America we will get through
the coronavirus to that day of renewed
health renewed prosperity that the
president always describes but we'll get
through there sooner and we'll get
through there when we work together
Thank You mr. vice president mr.
president thank you for your words of
discipline and determination I guess
that really describes what we're asking
every American to really be disciplined
about these guidelines and really
determined to stay in that space of
execution you know we are just in Week
three of this full guidance measure we
really do appreciate the work of the
citizens of California and Washington
state because we do see that their curve
is different their curve is different
from New York New Jersey and Connecticut
and we really believe that the work that
every citizen is doing in those states
is making a difference and it will make
a difference for the frontline health
care providers we also are deeply
grateful that despite the way their
curve looks today they continue to get
ready for a different potential so that
they can ensure that patients if they do
get sick have options and availability
to all the frontline health care workers
in the what we have referred to as hot
zones areas where the number of cases
are quite significant the New Orleans
the New York City metro area including
New Jersey and Connecticut the
incredible work that the frontline
health care workers are providing we're
really working now at a much more
granular level talking directly to
hospitals to ensure that they have the
supplies that they need in coordination
with state state and local governments
and to work I think we discussed it
yesterday but I think it was quite clear
also and reiterated by Governor Cuomo
today that we have to support one
another as each of these different metro
areas and other areas move through their
peak of new infections when we talked
about it at the beginning of this week
we talked about this week and next week
being incredibly difficult and we want
to recognize the number of
Americans who have lost their lives to
this virus
recognize the sacrifice that health care
providers are making both in their care
but I think where I'm very uplifted by
hearing their messages to families and
their compassion for others to provide
that kind of support to the individuals
in the hospital we continue to watch in
addition the Chicago area the Detroit
area and have some developing concerns
around Colorado the District of Columbia
and Pennsylvania so as you can see each
of these will follow their own curves it
will be getting more and more of those
case overtime information in a very
granular way to each and every one of
you strand Euler again follow these
epidemic epidemiologic curves as each of
these states counties and communities
move through this together in solidarity
and really ensuring that we can move
supplies creatively around the country
to meet the needs of both the frontline
healthcare providers but also every
American who needs our support right now
thank you
well thank you mr. president for your
continued leadership as we battle the
coronavirus first I want to thank all of
the members of the HHS team and the
frontline health care workers across
America including those who those
service workers who serve in our
hospitals and our health care facilities
those who clean those who deliver those
who stock the shelves all those who are
going into battle every day against the
virus
your country's asked you to serve as
never before and you have responded
heroically I'm gonna provide a brief
update on the administration's plans to
cover the testing and treatment for the
uninsured getting the uninsured access
to the care they need is a top priority
for President Trump this is important we
are already rolling out the 1 billion
dollars in funding from the families
first coronavirus response Act to cover
provider's expenses for testing and
diagnosing the uninsured not cover it
the cares Act signed by the president
includes another 100 billion dollars for
health care providers under the
president's direction we will use a
portion of that funding to cover
provider's costs of delivering kovat 19
care for the uninsured sending the money
to providers through the same mechanism
used for testing as a condition of
receiving funds under this program
providers will be forbidden from balance
billing the uninsured for the cost of
their care providers will be reimbursed
at Medicare rates we will soon have more
specifics on how the rest of the 100
billion dollars will go to providers
we're working to ensure that this
funding is distributed in a way that is
fast fair simple and transparent I'd
also like to remind people that if
you've lost employer insurance coverage
you have insurance options that you
should look into you'd be eligible for a
special enrollment period on the health
care exchanges and depending on your
state you may be eligible for Medicaid
just as president Trump is working to
ensure that kovat 19 treatment is paid
for he's working to support new
treatment options for patients
thanks to the president's leadership
many providers are trying different
experimental therapies and we need as
much data as we can collect as quickly
as possible on how these treatments are
working
today Oracle has developed and is
donating to the government and the
American people a web portal and
platform to gather crowd-sourced
real-time information from providers
about how patients respond to potential
therapeutics well this doesn't replace
the important work of clinical trials it
gives us data rapidly if you are a
doctor or a health care provider and you
would like to help us you can sign up
today to begin reporting on your work
there's a special registration page for
providers at kovat nineteen oracle.com
thank you for exciting new product for
coronavirus customers ok face masks what
do what would people gain from wearing a
mask and why are you opposed to wearing
one yourself I just don't wear one
myself it's a recommendation they
recommend it I'm feeling good I just
don't want to be doing I don't know
somehow sitting in the Oval Office
behind that beautiful resolute desk the
great resolute desk
I think wearing a face mask as I greet
presidents prime ministers dictators
kings queens I don't know somehow he's
greeting dictators in the Oval Office
maybe I'll change my mind but this will
pass and hopefully it'll pass very
quickly now with that being said if
somebody wants to most people could just
make something out of a certain material
so it's very well designated it's very
simple to do I won't be doing it
personally that's a recommendation ok
[Music]
surgeongeneral please the Surgeon
General who for weeks have been saying
masks do nothing okay mr. vice president
mr. secretary and CDC director Redfield
I especially want to thank the folks at
the CDC and it's a great question that
you asked it's a fair question that you
asked I want to unpack the evolution of
our guidance on mass because it has been
confusing to the American people yes
first of all I want people to understand
that the CDC the World Health
Organization my office in most public
health and health organizations and
professionals originally recommended
against the general public wearing masks
because based on the best evidence
available at the time it was not deemed
that that would have a significant
impact on whether or not a healthy
person wearing a mask would contract
kovat 19 we have always recommended that
symptomatic people wear a mask because
if you're coughing if you have a fever
if you're symptomatic you could transmit
disease to other people what has changed
in our recommendation well it's
important to know that we now know from
recent studies that a significant
portion of individuals with corona virus
lack symptoms they're what we call
asymptomatic and that even those who
eventually become pre-symptomatic
meaning that they will develop symptoms
in the future can transmit the virus to
others before they show symptoms this
means that the virus can spread between
people interacting in close proximity in
other words they were example coughing
speaking or sneezing even if those
people were not exhibiting symptoms in
light of this new evidence CDC
recommends and the Task Force recommends
wearing cloth face coverings in public
public settings where other social
distancing measures are difficult to
maintain these these include places like
grocery stores and pharmacies we
especially recommend this in areas of
significant community base to
transmission it is critical and the
president mentioned this the vice
president mentioned this it's critical
to emphasize that maintaining six feet
of social distancing remains key to
slowing the spread of the buyer
but CDC is additionally advising the use
of simple cloth coverings to slow the
spread of the virus and to help people
who may have the virus and do not know
it from transmitting it to others the
cloth face coverings recommended are not
surgical master in 95 respirators those
are critical supplies that must continue
to be reserved for healthcare workers
and other medical first responders as
recommended by the current CDC guidance
as the president also mentioned cloth
face coverings fashioned from household
items are made at home from common
materials at low cost can be used as an
additional voluntary public health
measure this recommendation complements
and does not replace the president's
coronavirus guidelines for America 30
days to slow the spread which remains
the cornerstone of our national effort
to slow the spread of the virus
CDC is always always looking at the data
we've told you that from the beginning
dr. Burke says it every single press
conference we're looking at the data
we're evolving our recommendations and
new recommendations will come as the
evidence dictates so I want to say if
you do choose to wear a face mask very
important wash your hands first because
you don't want to put on a face covering
with a dirty hand do not touch your face
while you are wearing the face covering
because again you could take materials
from the surface germs from the surface
and bring it to your face if you choose
to wear a face covering please please
leave the n95 mask the medical supplies
for the medical professionals health
care workers and frontline workers know
that this is not a substitute for social
distancing and remember this is all
about me protecting you and you
protecting me this is about us coming
together as communities and if people
voluntarily choose to wear a face face
covering they're wearing it to protect
their neighbors from getting the corona
virus because again they could have
asymptomatic spread so mr. president
thank you very much for that
appreciate the opportunity to update NHS
okay mr. president dr. foxy last may
have recommended it said that every
state should have stay-at-home orders
right now do you agree with that should
every state in this country have to kind
of stay at home workers that we now see
in places like walk up to the
government's the governors know what
they're doing they've been doing a great
job
I guess we're close to 90 percent anyway
and states that we're talking about are
not in jeopardy now I would leave it to
the governors I like I like that from
the standpoint of governing and I like
that from the standpoint of even our
Constitution announced yesterday right
we'll get you in go to the oil meeting
previous yeah is the u.s. willing to cut
domestic oil production what came out of
the meeting what was the consume a lot
of things came out it's a great industry
it's an important industry a tremendous
job producing industry we already had
tremendous industry on our on our floor
and it was also very interesting because
they all were given the test before they
came into the room so you have the head
of ExxonMobil you have all these guys
taking the test and they all passed with
flying colors so that was good
they left happy in that respect at least
there's just an overabundance of oil
right now
oil and gas tremendous overabundance and
it was caused they were doing a great
job they were producing a lot of energy
but then you had the virus come along
and it knocked another thirty five
percent maybe forty percent off of the
market so there's too much oil there's a
glut and these are great companies and
they'll figure out a spree market we'll
figure it out you spoke to President
Putin
I mean what's on the table here and
yeah they were having a competition
we'll see how it all works out I think
it's going to work out very well it's
going to take a long time to to get rid
of that this massive excess amount of
oil and gas massive like probably
there's never been oh so what that does
work out well I guess you could say is
for drivers
I think like you've never seen it before
I think that County I can get five cents
a gallon right down on the road but we
have a tremendous industry a great
industry a tremendously important
industry from the standpoint of jobs and
we're energy independent we have to make
sure we keep it that way all right
please administration to address the
source man plus apply announced
yesterday would ease the restrictions on
certain donors including gay men or now
required to be abstinent for three
months as opposed to 12 months to donate
a hand in that time no I didn't know
anything about that that was done by the
FDA very capable people at the FDA yes
mr. president
both the Government of Canada and 3m are
pushing back on this DPA not exports and
95 respirators yeah
3m says I don't blame them they can push
back anyone we're not happy with 3m yeah
I'm not happy and the people that dealt
with it directly are not at all happy
with 3m so we'll see whether or not we
do I heard what he had to say today I
don't know the gentleman but we're not
happy with 3m go ahead dr. pouchy I
don't know but every time you ask that
question whenever he's not here you look
you say where is he and you'll say is
there a problem no problem whatsoever
every time he's not here sometimes I'll
ask him to come because that's the first
question that you and a couple of others
from the fake news establishment ask is
always taken you know cheese that on
here we're doing great
together we're covering a different
subject today go ahead
go ahead it's 9:00 mr. president you
have said nobody could have seen this
pandemic coming but in fact secretary a
czar at a bio defense summit in April 20
1999 flu of course I think everyone in
this room probably shares that concern
your own Health and Human Services
Secretary was aware that this had
potential
I'm an idiot oh my god I want a pandemic
of this nature I'm an idiot who dropped
the ball well I always knew that
pandemics are one of the worst things
could happen there's been nothing like
this since probably 1917 that was the
big one in Europe it started actually
here and went to Europe probably I've
heard about she has made wait a minute
let me finish I've heard about this for
a long time pandemics you don't want
pandemics and I don't think he was
talking about a specific pandemic he was
talking about the threat of a pandemic
could happen and it could happen feel
like we're gonna get in some of those
wouldn't and most people didn't
understand the severity of it this is
very severe what's happened is very
severe but I'd let you answer that I
assume that he was talking about the
concept of a pandemic Thank You mr.
president
activated absolutely for 15 years now
this country is at a massive effort at
the federal state and local level of
preparedness for pandemic now that
largely has been as I said in those
remarks about pandemic flu preparedness
we knew about SARS we knew about MERS
which were earlier modifications or
variants of the corona virus
none of those achieved anything like
what we're seeing today but that's why
for successive presidencies including
the leadership of President Trump there
has been a great focus on pandemic
preparedness in fact if November I
believe that the President signed the
pandemic flu permits someone else yes
they're a difficult question that we
have we've and we have also updated the
pandemic Francis action plan which has
been the playbook from which we've been
working the pandemic flu plan the again
the action plan from which we have been
working that coordinates the
whole-of-government hole
economy approach here so we've all been
very focused on pandemic preparedness
that's what we do but this particular
strain of pandemic who would who would
have known this particular strain the
secretaries are if you are preparing for
a pandemic at this government we're
preparing for a pandemic why is it we
don't have enough masks
why is it we don't have enough medical
equipment in the previous
administrations gave us very little
ammunition there it is very and very
little shelf spend let me just oh yeah
you know it you know the answer the
previous administration boom shelves
were empty the shelves were empty so
what you should do is speak to the
people from the previous administration
there it is and ask them that question
because the shelves were at the end you
know what else the military shelves were
also empty
we had no ammunition literally that was
at the life said by one of your favorite
generals we have sir
we have no ammunition there it is this
very little medical supply also alright
we'll get you back please watch it my
said we'll get you back please say you
said that there will be a ban on
exporting of all what does it cover it
so masks gloves what else is everything
order are you but if somebody ordered if
Italy if Spain who has big problems
these have these are countries with
tremendous crumbs France if they ordered
if they have long-term orders and
they're in there and they want to get
certain things I've let them go out in
certain instances because I think it's
only fair they have problems that are
proportionately or relatively bigger
than our problems so if they ordered
something and they're waiting for as an
example masks made here and going to
Italy I'm not going to be stopping that
I think would be very unfair and by the
way speaking about being fair and unfair
to very big cruise liners as you know
when you live on the dock today we
worked with the governor of Florida as
you know run to Santos now I didn't
worked on it and we had tremendous
security and we took the sick people and
we're
can with them we have doctors we have
great doctors military doctors and from
a humane standpoint not that we're in
love with this these are two massive
ships but we have to take care of people
we have to take care of we sent many
back to Canada the candidate the
Canadians came and worked very closely
with us as did the UK we have I'm saying
this thing Toto is not taking this we've
gotta do Americans we took care of the
sick weeks in the last 15 minutes
basically have been him not taking
responsibility for maybe five people
that had died on the boat that one of
the boats actually and we had to take
care of these people
so we could have let him float aimlessly
into the ocean looking for port as
they've been doing for a long time and I
made the decision we had to take him in
and Homeland Security and a lot of other
people did a great job but we had to
help people these are people that were
very very sick some were dying some died
your staff they said that people close
proximity to you and the vice president
will get a coronavirus test I'm
wondering are you concerned that the
people you've been hanging around with
may have the virus
no not good soon no yeah I had a test
yesterday for the order for people who
meet with you or talk to you from the
oil executives these are people most of
them had not had the test and frankly I
think they left the room feeling good
about a lot of things but they felt good
about the test this was a test it took I
guess 13 minutes to have it finalized
say they took the test I don't know I
didn't know they were doing that maybe
they did it just for them I don't know
but it seems that a lot of people
because now we have tests that really
worked well Abbott in this case habit we
have other tests being developed right
now that are also fantastic the original
tests the ones we inherited Jim is an
example there's about to be the bathroom
were broken obsolete they were not good
tests and that's what we got stuck with
we've developed some incredible tests
but this took 13 to 15 minutes and
Counting it's got it
the problem some people have have raised
is that if the US stopped exporting what
you could have is other countries than
deciding reciprocally that they are
going to stop exporting and then the
result of that then will be a net
decrease in the amount of supplies that
American doctors American hospitals have
how do you address that
well I dress it in the following manner
we really are very well supplied we are
not the principal it's the hospital's
the states the cities they're supposed
to get everything they can and stock up
in case something like this happens but
nobody could ever assume that something
like this happens so we started
supplying we brought tremendous amounts
to New York today and over the last few
days we brought him to Louisiana we
brought him to Michigan we brought him
to Los Angeles a lot of equipment you've
read the amount of masks that we had I
think I said over 8 million masks the
n95 masks the you know more expensive
more complicated but got no one could
have predicted Rask's the ones that want
to use in the hospitals we have millions
of them now and we've given them to a
lot we sent to Bellevue in New York
today that was from here to Blasio
200,000 of them but we have 8.1 million
we're going to have more than that and
we're getting them from various sources
including the military we're rapidly
then replacing them because we have to
replace them in case there's a another
emergency I would be of gowns too we
have many gowns being delivered and have
been delivered our people have done an
incredible job
most people have said no and this
yesterday governors have said thank you
for most people have said many people in
some cases not in all cases at all if I
said here's a thousand ventilators how
many do you want we want 1,000 here's a
thousand you got them but you know we're
gonna do we're gonna add another 5,000
is that good they said wow that's great
and then if Jim Acosta goes and says are
you happy with the president no we
should have given us 10,000 that's
what's happening you know why cuz that's
a standard political answer and that's a
shame because we have done a job like
nobody's
ever done a job but we've just delivered
a lot of masks we've just delivered a
lot of gowns and protective gear but you
know you're talking about a massive
you're talking about a massive number
but as of this morning people were very
very happy Steve dancing are loud it was
really more of a discussion than asking
we just got you know we did discuss the
concept of tariffs because as you know
this was a dispute among a couple of
countries that I think they want to be
able to get itself to they had a dispute
they had a competition but they want to
get a reserved Russia and Saudi Arabia
you know I think they want to get it
yeah I think they want to get it
resolved I think they're working very
hard I mean they told me they want to
get it resolved they're working very
hard thank you yesterday Jared Kushner
said the notion of the federal stockpile
was it supposed to be our stockpile it's
not supposed to be state stockpiles that
they then by our you know what hour
means the United States of America
that's what it made made up in 60 state
our hour it means the United States of
America and then we take that hour and
we distribute it to the states not
either not supposed to be state
stockpiles because we need it for the
government and we needed for the federal
government but with a snake water it's
okay to the state to keep to keep for a
country because the federal government
needs a to not just the states but out
of that we oftentimes choose as an
example we have almost 10,000
ventilators and we are ready to rock
with those ventilators we're going to
bring them to various areas of the
country that need them but when he says
our he's talking about our country he's
talking excuse me he's talking about the
federal government he's making it the
thing should be inside a basic simple
question and you try and make it sound
so bad you ought to be you ought to be
ashamed of yourself oh [ __ ]
it's such a simple question it's not he
said our an hour means for the country
an hour means for the states because the
states are part of monotony they don't
make it sound bad don't make it sound
bad go ahead Steve Wow back here
breakers you just ask you a question
you just ask you a question in a very
nasty time there it is nasty let's go
give you a perfect answer you know
perfect we had that too when we have the
Oh perfect this check file I mean isn't
that designed to be a little distribute
to the stage sure but it's also needed
for the federal government
we have a federal sock pile and they
have state stockpiles and frankly they
were many of the states were totally
unprepared for this so we had to go into
the federal stockpile but we're not an
ordering clerk they have to have for
themselves now some of the states were
in good shape some of the states were
not in good shape that's probably
something you could expect
we have been helping States we have a
tremendous amount of time effort and
billions and billions of dollars when
making sure that they have what they
have
I mean take New York we built them
hospitals I built them for hospitals
built a Medical Center's sent a ship
with a thousand rooms than twelve
operating rooms and and then on top of
that gave vast numbers of ventilators
and vast numbers of surgical gowns
equipment masks everything else LML say
it they had a chance to order
ventilators over the years they had a
chance to order a very big but they
didn't choose to do it we were there and
we helped them and I think the governor
of New York is very thankful for the
help that we gave but we have a
stockpile it's a federal stockpile we
can use that for states or we can use it
for ourselves
we do use it for the federal government
we have a very big federal government
guys use their powers to give us
a traffic cop for all the essential
medical supplies there was a traffic cop
we're a humanitarian come we help it's
like the ship's do you think we wanted
to take two big ships into our country
that have obvious problems and you know
the problems I'm talking about and it's
K so I have a decision to make
do I take them in or do I save lives
okay do I take a bin or do I said I
decided to take them in and we have
tremendous protection we have great
doctors there to help the people they
had four or five people that died that
was as of last night they died in the
ships we took care of it and now the
people are in the process of and many
are already back in Canada they're back
in the UK United Kingdom and many of
them were American citizens some were
very sick we're taking care of the sick
people we're testing all of the others
very very carefully very very carefully
they are being tested like you wouldn't
believe and we solve a humanitarian
catastrophe you know why
with like nobody else you take the ships
nobody else would take them now so we
doctor Minh I think for today why why
you don't say we're the federal
government's and there's a shortage of
massive things and we're going we do say
that we so we say and we use the act
excuse me
we do say that and we use the act and
we've used it a number of times very
powerfully oh and a lot of times they
don't have music because we say we're
going to use it if you don't do this or
that and then we also have companies
that act incredibly well we have plenty
of them mostly them but we've used the
act very powerfully oh you don't have to
exercise the act all you have to do is
help look if you don't do this we're
going to use the act and we've done a
good job with it maybe a great job yeah
mr. president there are news reports
that you want to sign the
stimulus checks that are going out here
in several months is that right the
phoenicians I know there's millions of
checks I'm gonna sign them no it's a
trump administration initiative but do I
want to sign him no the people are
getting - people are getting their money
there's a lot of stimulus going in a lot
of different ways there's also stimulus
going for companies that would if it
weren't for our government would not and
some companies that were very strong a
month ago again we had the strongest
economy in the world we had our best
ever we had probably the best economy in
the history of the world bigger than
China bigger than anybody else China and
one day we have to say close it up stop
everybody go home and you know what it's
pretty tough to do that I can tell you
is the small business today is they were
way ahead of schedule there is a problem
where and which I pointed out I said you
shouldn't do it this way with
unemployment we're 40-year old equipment
by the states we're sending the money to
the states once the money is sent to the
states in the States whether they're
Republican or Democrat have to get the
money out to the people hopefully they
will it be able to do it but many of
those states have 40 year old computers
I don't know that they're equipped I
wanted to give the money direct if
that's what you're talking about I
wanted to give the money out direct it
would have been much easier but the
Democrats and some people said no let's
do it the complicated way stimulus
Jackson
all right well I was joking about it
there I was talking about both yeah yeah
they will go ahead please
thank you sir I'd like to ask questions
book for myself and some of the other
reporters who are in the room social
distancing first of all and this is for
yourself and dr. Burks what percentage
of the population do we suspect to be
asymptomatic at this point so our way to
to figure that out it seems like the
antibody test might be able to assist in
thank you so while we're working
diligently in the midst of the crisis to
make sure that the health care workers
and everyone who is sick gets provided
for at the same time we're working on
tests and assays that will be critical
for surveillance and at the same time
working on plans for what we need to do
as this moves through the population and
we get on the downside we're not there
yet and hopefully most of the states
will say like California and Washington
and then what we need to do to be
prepared for false so all three of those
things are happening simultaneously and
there's people working on each one of
those work streams the antibody piece is
critical as you described because at
this time we can't if we have let's say
asymptomatic status is inversely
asymptomatic status is inversely related
to age and so the younger you are the
more likely you are to be asymptomatic
we have to know that because we have to
know how many people have actually
become infected so when we talked about
five days ago I think on Monday I called
on universities to work on analyzer
based tests to test for their their
health workers and really get through
that at the same time the private sector
is working on tests and what do we want
those tests to be we want those tasks to
be like what we use for HIV and malaria
finger-prick
onto a cassette you get a line if your
positive and your control line negative
the line isn't there and there's the
control line that's what that's our
dream assay because it's a finger prick
in the meantime we're not waiting I mean
we're pushing for that at the same time
we're asking to develop an assay think
Eliza based assay which requires a tube
of blood and that's why we're also
talking about could we use dried blood
spots we also put our call directly out
to the military because of the Roosevelt
to really test all of the sailors on the
Roosevelt with an antibody test to get
to this critical issue of asymptomatic
and already pre-existing antibody that
would be if the first responders knew
they already had had it and they had
protective antibody if the nurses knew
the doctors knew if your schoolteacher
knew then it's a very different dialogue
so we understand the importance of that
and we understand how important it is in
relationship to understanding this
epidemic one other comment because I I
know we're always saying who knew what
when I just want to make clear there's a
hundred and fifty plus countries working
on this collectively together it's
devastating for every single country
when we get through this we can go back
and look at what happened where and and
what does this epidemic look like then
when you get through it then you can
validate every model there is known to
man when you're in the middle of it you
have to concentrate on serving the needs
of each American and what that need
looks like at the same time you have
these other work streams on surveillance
and how to be prepared both
scientifically and therapeutically and
vaccine wise for the next fall if that
happens again so I think these things
are happening together but I just want
us to really concentrate on the fact
that all around the globe country after
country is dealing with this and we can
talk about why didn't Italy do something
or Spain do something or Germany do
something or we can really say right now
we Cal can do something
we can do the social distancing and all
of the pieces that we know is starting
to work around the globe in country
after country complex is really boiling
it through all of this we can ask the
questions about could we have done some
piece of this better as a global
community I will remind you that on
February 3rd the head of the w-h-o said
there was no reason to ever do a travel
ban you know it wasn't until January
14th that we knew that there was human
to human transmission we met President
was saying this was going to go away
it's April this president you said it
was going to go in away in April you got
an April like America no no there's a
law but a very good mr. president on the
insurance coverage for treatment when
your government is going is trying to
make sure that people are covered on a
treatment we're going to do it
does that include the 11 million people
who are in this country illegally at a
different yeah please president will you
release authorize the release of the
underlying data for the conclusion of
the 100,000 and 240,000 people
succumbing and perhaps dr. Burks the
supply works these experts have
expressed concern that they haven't seen
the underlying data they're not sure
they'll talk to you about that and dr.
Faust you too please
for you and secretary aids are 10
million people say they've lost their
jobs in the past two weeks so how is
this tenuous money for free treatment
going to absorb the new numbers of
uninsured and would it not be easier to
do reopen the Obamacare markets or
expand Medicaid so for an individual who
had employer insurance that's what I
mentioned in my remarks if you were
employed and had insurance through your
employer and you've now lost your job
and lost that insurance you now do have
a special enrollment period where you
may enroll in the individual exchanges
of the Affordable Care Act so though
that's existing law then what we're
doing is taking from that hundred
billion dollars to providers taking
money and saying if you're a provider
and you care for anybody who's uninsured
we're going to compensate you for doing
that and we're gonna compensate you at
the Medicare reimbursement rates and you
are not allowed to build that uninsured
individual anything so in many respects
it's better for those uninsured
individuals they're gonna get first
dollar coverage they're gonna get care
in the United States and the provider is
gonna be made whole from this program so
it's really an unprecedented on what
President Trump is doing here with this
money is an unprecedented what they're
saying is coded they're basically not
answering about undocumented immigrants
but they're saying you'll go to the
hospital you won't have insurance nobody
will ask about your immigration status
one specifically on New York and the
question of ventilators Governor Cuomo
was saying that New York may be days
away a truck from running out of
ventilators can you assure New York that
going into next week they're gonna have
those ventilators that they're gonna
you know they should have had more
ventilators at the time they should have
had more ventilators they were totally
under serviced we are trying to do we're
doing our best for New York you know we
have we have states we have a lot of
states we have territories to but we
have didn't know that other states that
have to be taken care of some much more
so than others we've worked very well
with the governor we happen to think
that he's well served with ventilators
we're gonna find out but we have other
states
we'll find out if I drop em in Louisiana
we have a big problem in Michigan we
have a big problem and seven other
really strong hotspots but we're doing
the best we can I wish they did the
original orders three years ago they
would have had all the ventilators they
needed although even then they wouldn't
because if you look at what the original
request was from New York it was far
greater than anybody ever heard and
we've we've supplied a lot I told you we
supplied some just today to New York and
we supplied some yesterday to New York
City was so important I don't think it
was a very important what you drank with
Jared Kushner said yesterday is that the
federal stockpile is for use by the
federal government not for the states to
have access to so you seem to be saying
differently to Jared cooker misspeak
yesterday no he's that federal in the
stockpile he used the word hour okay our
hours referring to our country the
states to the best of my knowledge and
to the best of your knowledge are a part
of our country right you're taking what
is in the federal stockpile and we are
helping States all over the country but
we also want to keep some because when
that surge comes when you hit those
peaks we're going to need we have to be
able to have the flexibility to take
those ventilators and bring them to
Louisiana New York Detroit they also
said so but the word base we're not
using them anywhere else we're not gonna
be using them John anywhere else
but we want the flexibility in cuz you
know we don't even know when the surge
is coming but it's coming so yes we do
know exactly and some areas won't happen
some areas will be pleasantly surprised
just like we've been you look at the
states that I thought would have been
maybe a disaster turned out to be really
they've done a great job some states are
really trouble but you don't know you
don't know we have great flexibility
I would have preferred giving them all
out we'd have nothing and now when we
have a surge we can't get them back from
where we gave it because it's very tough
to take them back so we have tremendous
flexibility and it could be New York it
could be Louisiana those are two that
are really rough New Jersey is very
rough and they've done a very good job
in New Jersey but New Jersey's rough go
ahead please about the guidelines
relative to which social distancing
group and so on and now we have this
this measure about wearing masks and I
know you told Steve about why you don't
want to wear a mask but I'm just
wondering if you can tell us more about
why because it was use for example
they're not mandatory guidelines they're
guidelines they guess you could wear
them you don't have to wear them in fact
the director is here if you want to say
a couple of words about it you can if
you want you don't have to but basically
it's it's a voluntary thing
done a good job thank you very much I
think I just want to re-emphasize this
redfield I've said this before that
we're not defenseless against this virus
we have a powerful tool a powerful
weapon that is social distancing and
we've continued to embrace that with the
president's initiatives to slow the
spread of Carano virus we're constantly
looking at new data and as the Surgeon
General said one of the new information
that became more clear to all of us is
there's a greater a number of people
that are innocent Jason thematically
infected than we previously thought as
ambassador Burke said that may be
inversely related to age and so really
the purpose here fasteners a greater
burden is that right the social
distancing that's the number one thing
that's the powerful weapon and you know
this virus has a great weakness it can't
jump from one person to another if it's
got to swim more than six feet and this
is why we really want that that said we
now know that there may be individuals
in significant areas a significant
community transmission that may be
asymptomatic aliy in
and we know that a face barrier and
actually interrupt the number of virus
particles that can go for one person
together so as was said by the vice
president this is the president the
purpose of this face covering is to be
another objective mitigation strategy to
protect someone from spreading the virus
from themselves to someone else oh she
wasn't a ser she gets to keep the title
I assume I don't have the virus so I
have to worry about spreading it okay
please mr. president want to make sure
we're clear when you mentioned
terrorists earlier they came up in a
meeting
are you considering tariffs on Saudi
Arabian oil and in all systems look
tariffs have made a tremendous amount of
money for our country I put them on
China I put them on other places and
other countries tariffs US and they take
advantage of us and they have for many
years
look countries have taken advantage of
the United States for years they've
ripped us off like nobody can even
believe whether it be on on
manufacturing whether it be on exporting
whether it be on almost anything
including military well we provide
virtually free military assistance to
countries that frankly take advantage of
us don't even like us okay so this has
been going on for years
they tariff us they create artificial
you could say non-financial barriers
which are worse than financial barriers
you can't sell your product you can't
take care of our farmers they won't take
our and yet they'll take us and sell
into us and we won't charge them
anything for doing it look they've taken
advantage of us for years
tariffs are a way of evening the score
remember tariffs are away it's just a
neutralizing they have tariffs on us and
we now can put tariffs on them am I
using it for oil it's something we can
know am i doing it now no am I thinking
about imposing it as of this moment no
but if we're not treated fairly it's
certainly a tool in the toolbox
about with Russia are you what you
consider maybe lifting sanctions or
giving some thanks for the same thing be
the same thing they are having a dispute
the two countries and it's hurting the
rest of the world because it's really
hurting the energy industry Russia's
being hurt unbelievably badly and Saudi
Arabia's being hurt unbelievably badly
because oil and gas is a primary that's
where they get most of their income yeah
and this is a price like from the 1950s
all right it's a price from the 1950s
they are being hurt very badly I think
they're gonna settle their dispute
pretty quickly that's what they've done
they've increased it so much that this
so you meant the opposite well they're
going to stop because the market
ultimately the market is going to get
them to stop but they both did the
opposite they increase production to a
level that water is right now more
valuable than oil who would have ever
thought right you go to you go to some
of these kingdoms water is far more
valuable than oil there's so much oil
it's a tribute in a way but what
happened is there was a lot to start off
with and then you had the virus and it
knocked the hell out of the market in
terms of demand so there's no demand and
this tremendous supply would have
missile I mean you saw numbers where it
was down to 20 and down frankly below 20
it was even below 20 it's an incredible
thing the market but ultimately the
marketplace will take care of it
but I think they're gonna work out their
problem fairly doesn't yet seem to be
sweating Thank You mr. president we're
already talking about phase four of a
stimulus right
but you and Pelosi and McConnell are
already talking about different things
that should be in it now last time
people were telling me that the fact
that you wouldn't talk to Pelosi was a
pediment and it really slowed things
down are you talking we're important to
talk try to talk to her if it were
important for the American people I
talked to her but other than that I can
have other people talking to her
look you ready infrastructure is a great
thing for me
I think infrastructure for this country
we have an old broken infrastructure 50
years ago we were the envy of the world
and then we spent all this money so
stupidly in the Middle East we spent
it's going to be very close to eight
trillion dollars in the Middle East how
stupid was that decision but they spent
it on that and other things we've got to
fix our infrastructure that means roads
highways tunnels airports everything we
got to fix our reference and the beauty
is because of the fact that we are so
strong as a country were borrowing at
zero we never had a chance to borrow
here even this country we never had a
chance to borrow zero we're gonna borrow
this is a great time so we can fix our
infrastructure and we'll have almost no
interest cost this is the time to do it
Steve one more question you told
subjection that you shared with us
earlier this week are we still on the
current trajectory for that or have so
leisure which one I'm in hijackers are
many think 4,100 to 40,000 are we still
on that trajectory or have we made you
the improvements or maybe not enough
safe saying sassy have we made enough
approve in
I do not as dr. Fauci and not have to
ever have the models changed so a lot of
the projections you can see are based on
there's many different ways to look at
this and as we discussed on Sunday some
of it is based on the current global
experience we are about I think six
point five or five point five times the
size of Italy a different factor in
Spain and we look at all of those what
their projections are where they are
currently and where that is going and so
a lot of the work is based on how this
virus has moved through other
populations that's a very direct way to
see how the virus is impacting a
populations there's also terrific models
and so every day and every night one of
the models that actually looks at the
model related to mortality is the health
data dot org data and they update it
every night and you can see where we are
in that projection I think in the last
run of that model they were at 93
thousand or something in the model now
all of that can be changed by our
behaviors and so and all of it can be
changed in a different way if we don't
follow those behaviors if another major
metropolitan area ends up having an
epidemic like the New York metro area
that could dramatically change not the
model but the reality of the impact of
this virus on Americans
the professionals did the models I was
never involved in a model we know you're
not a member but is this kind of a model
imagine Trump make hundreds of thousands
this kind of a model Wow I want much
less than that I want none but it's too
late for that but I want very few people
relative to what the models are saying
those are projections I hope they're
wrong I hope we're going to be under
those projections
imagine if Trump was involved in the
model or Rubio - what can you have one
well they're real every time I have
three questions I have two quick can you
give me one instead just get a couple of
other people good okay I'll go in my
second one I the governor of Wisconsin
is not talking about delaying the
primary at least not have to get a
person voting so my question is and I
asked this a couple weeks ago was the
humidity's progress on this looking
ahead to the fall are you taking steps
to ensure that the general election will
happen even if this pandemic has
re-emerged or hasn't gone away the
general actual happen on November 3rd in
Wisconsin what happened is I through
social media media put out a very strong
endorsement of a Republican draw a bit
of judge who was being accelerated
brilliant judge he's a justice and I
hear what happened is his poll numbers
went through the roof and because of
that I think they delayed the election
about people going to enforce them I
don't know he why didn't you do it
before he's doing right before the
election do you think scuse me why did
he do this two weeks ago all of a sudden
kismet all of a sudden an election which
is taking place very soon gets delayed
now I just endorsed him today and it was
a very strong endorsement his polls he's
gone very high up and all of a sudden
the governor comes out the Democrat
governor by the way comes out and says
oh we're gonna move this election so I
don't know I'm sure I hope you're right
I hope you what do you think every state
in this country should be prepared for
mailing voting no a lot of people cheat
with mail-in voting
I think people derrida with ID voter I
don't want it
I think voter ID is very important and
the reason they don't want voter ID is
because they intend to cheat when you
get something when you buy
something you look at your cards and
credit cards and different cards you
have your picture and many of them not
all of them but are many of them almost
no one does you should have a picture on
your on your voting it should be called
voter ID they should have that and it
shouldn't be mail an excuse member Trump
previously said you need an ID to buy
cereal you go to a booth and you proudly
display yourself you don't send it in
the mail where people pick up all sorts
of bad things can happen by the time
they sign that if they sign that if they
sign that by the time it gets in as
tabulated no it shouldn't be mailed in
you should vote at the booth and you
should have voter ID because when you
have voter ID that's the real deal thank
you very much voter ID it almost sounds
like he's saying voter ID like photo
okay so I think bingo went pretty well
today I looks like I have double bingo
almost just one short of both diagonals
does middle and the four corners count I
guess I have triple bingo in that sense
so anyway I'll take a screenshot of this
and then tweeted out so for the next one
please email me it's too crazy to pay
attention to the chat one that we do
this tell me which of these elements
should be removed and which one's should
I add for the next bingo okay I think we
probably need to have fake news ratings
maybe shouldn't be here very strongly
you know he said very strong twice maybe
you should be very strong /li so you've
got to email me okay you go to my
website and you tell me which ones
should be out and what should I put in
and then we can you know we'll deal with
that entire thing but I think it does
add an interesting element for lack of a
better term to these press briefings so
we will do that again next time that we
do it let me say a few membership
thank-yous because there are some
amazing people who signed up Kamil Todd
grabbed membership number 42 on my
website diane scrip
pick is new-member number 43 Spencer
Meadows is new member number 44 Roni
Brothers is new member number 45
Joe Augustine is new member number 46 I
want to say thanks to Mathis James at
number 47 today
parth Eubanks leach is new member number
48 today Wow Ruby Alcala number 49
Steve's Patel is number 50 huge huge
huge joke rockin Berg is number 51
Jess Gould was number 52 today it was a
real party on the website
Paul Sandstrom was number 53 and John
Lothian was number 54 wow this is crazy
I want to say thanks to Susan and Nikki
who upgraded her membership and I say
count it also John Roach EO was number
56 and let me see if I missed anybody
else here no that gets us caught up
incredible incredible performance today
I really do want to congratulate all of
you guys on that we will be back with
the next stream sometime I'm probably
not doing tomorrow's I'm on an official
mental health break from Trump for
probably the next 48 hours so I'll
probably be back on Sunday probably
won't do the stream tomorrow if there is
one thank you to everybody who joined me
subscribe like follow you guys know all
this stuff by this point